... mit der Kurs des Ländschen Vakulier ist der Ort.
Chaos, wir sind verbunden.
Gründung der Verletzung.
Geben uns die Kraft und die Kontrolle.
Oh, Abnormale sind getrunken.
Blutfeuer, den wir benötigen.
Es fließt in die schwarzen Wälder.
Unvergesslich.
In der Nacht, ist das dein Befehl.
In der Zeit, sind es schwarze Menschen, die zufrieden sind.
Es fließt von außen.
Der Tod ist übergezogen.
Es geht um die Unbekannten.
Sie fließen. Sie brechen.
Das Ende des Unerhörten.
Sie verbreiten die Füße.
Sie fließen. Sie brechen.
Das Ende des Unerhörten.
Die Kraft und die Kontrolle.
Bunn Rich.
Sie brechen. Sie brechen.
Deshalb sind sie abversorgt.
Hej Hringис, ich schöne Musik.
Es ist nicht seamisch thicker.
Boah.
Jetzt müsste ich noch eine Runde so Wikinger, Deathmetal Zeug anmachen.
Aber das geht ja nicht weil Monkathors...
machst du nix.
Bitte den Archifling im links unten... habe ich da einen Archifling?
Ach, das gibt's ja mehr. Tja, tatsächlich.
Ja, es ist gut, dass du es gesagt hast.
Wie bearbeite man das überhaupt gescheit hier?
Einfach nur Archif wegmachen?
Oh, save? Nee, wird nicht redirected.
Wird nicht redirected.
Oh, das muss auch HTTPS sein, dass es funktioniert, nicht HTTPS.
Editier's mal kurz. HTTPS. Jetzt stimmt's.
Nee, wird nicht redirected. Probier's aus.
Ach so. Ja, mit HTTPS wird's redirected. Okay, das kann sein.
Aber das war noch ein Link auf HTTPS. HTTPS Archif.
Das wird nicht redirected.
Ja, jetzt geht's, aber mit HTTPS ging's nicht.
Also habe ich eben ausprobiert, aber nicht funktioniert.
Ah, der Sebaro wieder.
Theoretisch musst du auch auf HTTPS nicht antworten, sondern der Web-Server sollte automatisch redirecten.
Ja, ist ja auch leider meistens so.
Aber der Sebaro ist genug beschäftigt, da muss ich mit irgendwelchen nervigen Schülern rumschlagen.
Ich hätte so keinen Bock drauf Lehrer zu sein, Leute, ich sag's euch.
Lehrer ist glaube ich so ziemlich das Abartigste, was ich mir vorstellen kann.
Ich mein, würdet ihr freiwillig Lehrer werden?
Also ja, ich weiß, es gibt manche, die das machen, aber ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen.
Nee, er ist im Leben nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was denn Sebaro da reicht, dass der Lehrer werden will, Alter.
Aber gut, hey, ich mein, irgendeiner muss es ja machen.
Irgendeiner...
Ich mein, wenn es keiner macht, ist er auch doof.
Was los, heute Ärger drauf? Was, heute gut drauf wurde Ärger?
Wieso?
Ich hör noch, ups, ich hör normalerweise
größteil meiner Zeit, wenn ich Musik anhabe, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Aber ich kann halt meistens nichts im Stream anmachen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich kenn das.
Ich weiß, dass man in Woz, das muss ich mir echt unbedingt mal angucken,
dass in Woz die Musik ausgetauscht wird.
Ich mach jetzt aber trotzdem ein bisschen was weniger Anstrengendes an.
Okay, jetzt vielleicht, wir gehen jetzt vielleicht nicht von
Hellsinger aus zu
Song and Smiles.
Song and Smiles, Happy and Upbeat Nintendo Music.
Das Kontrast ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu hart, oder?
Ja, lieber ein bisschen Wupp, Wupp, Wupp an.
Moin, Probearbeiten war heute heftig.
Ja, warum? Erzähl. Du hast irgendwas gesagt, wo du dich beworben hast.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen. Du hast gestern was geschrieben.
War das gestern irgendwas geschrieben?
Nee, Nintendo Musik, Game Music. Ach, Def.
Ach, DevOps und Windows Zeug.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen, dass das heftig war.
Ich mein, Windows alleine ist ja schon abfuck genug.
Nee, Gameplay, also Gaming Musik geht eigentlich immer in Streams.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Keg Weight.
Die haben aber ein geiles Deployment Card.
Ich frag mich, wie man Windows geil deploit.
Also wisst ihr, was die geilste, soll ich euch mal zeigen,
was die geilste Variante ist, um Windows zu deployen?
Debian Downloaden.
Das ist die beste Variante.
Das ist die beste Art, wie man Windows deploit.
Also, haben die da auch Windows auf Servern?
Oh, Girls.
Haben die da auch Windows auf Servern?
Boah. Ach, du Scheiße.
Oh, Gott.
Oh, Gott, bitte nicht.
Fick dich weg, du Homo-Fürst.
Sonst gastriere ich dir die Eier.
Alter, 800 Windows Server.
Ich kann mir ja kaum was Schlimmeres vorstellen.
Aber jetzt war unabhängig davon.
Nur weil ich das nicht mag.
Also nicht, dass der Job schlecht sein muss.
Ich könnte mir bloß nichts vorstellen.
800 Windows Server, meine Güte.
Also wir hatten zu Spitzenzeiten...
Wartet mal ein Sekund.
Ich mache ein bisschen was Verträglicheres
für die Leute im Stream an hier.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, sehr gut.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Also auf der alten Arbeit hatten wir so zu...
Spitzenzeiten, glaube ich, so...
Ja, 3000 Linux-Systeme ungefähr.
Ich rechne VMs mit.
Muss ich dazu sagen, in dem Fall.
Also logische Server.
Ich glaube, in der Spitzenzeit so um 3
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr, so 3000
Linux-Systeme zu Spitzenzeiten.
Und das war schon eklig.
Das alles irgendwie den Überblick zu behalten.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass nur ein Bruchteil davon
Windows ist, boah, da würde ich ja durchdrehen.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Ja, so ist es.
Selbst Microsoft hat ihren Kram mittlerweile auf Linux.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Aha.
Ach so, die Anwendung ist von euch.
Ja, gut.
Hier mittlerweile sogar Windows Konjura.
Das ist Fake. Das ist irgendwelcher Fake Hyper-Wii-Müll
unter der Haube, oder? Ist Docker für Windows
nicht Hyper-Wii unter der Haube, was den kompletten Sinn von
Docker, also generell von Containern irgendwie
in Frage stellt, wenn es dann doch wieder VMs sind?
Na gut, die einfache Handhabung mit Docker
als CLI-Tool und so bleibt ja weiterhin bestehen.
Aber so auf größeren
Maßstäben ist es ziemlich, ziemlich unsinnig.
Ja, ich weiß, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Komm mal, nur weil ich das ein bisschen schlecht mache,
muss das kein schlechter Job sein, bzw. muss das auch keine
schlechte Arbeit sein.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man auch im Windows-Umfeld
spaßige und interessante Sachen machen kann.
Vielleicht, ja. Also ich hätte da bloß
keinen Bock drauf. Ja, nee, also es ist wichtig,
dass es dir gefällt und was ist, was dich
von der Technologie auch anspricht.
Ich dachte ja immer wieder im Stream, nur weil ich was kacke finde,
heißt ja nicht wirklich, dass es automatisch auch
universal global kacke sein muss.
Außer C++ vielleicht.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Hast du da einen Probearbeitstag gemacht,
weil du noch überlegst, ob du unterschreibst oder bist du
schon mehr oder weniger sicher, dass du unterschreibst?
Vieles ist Hyper-V, tatsächlich. Man muss
allerdings gucken. Also, nee, einfach nur so.
Man muss aber auch gucken,
vor allem, weil Windows 10 das Emoji nicht kann.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Fuck. Ja, man muss auch gucken,
wenn man Hyper-V einschaltet unter Windows 11,
falls ihr euch fragt, warum manche Sachen nicht gehen,
wenn ihr Hyper-V oder den Hyper-V Workload nennt,
das glaube ich bei Windows, keine Ahnung, was da bei Microsoft
was ist.
Überlegst, ja.
Aber scheint ein ganz guter Job zu sein. Wenn die automatisiert das
Deployment haben, sogar auf Kundensysteme, das ist
seltene Kombination, dass sie das auch erlauben,
dann scheint der Laden ja schon mal nicht so schlecht zu sein.
Was wollte ich da eigentlich noch? Wenn ihr unter Windows 10
Hyper-V aktiviert und so ist gar kein Problem, wenn ihr allerdings,
da müsst ihr aufpassen, kann ich euch als eigene Erfahrung sagen,
wenn ihr Windows 11 habt und aktiviert Hyper-V,
aktiviert Windows unter der Haube auch noch irgendwelche
Isolation-Security-Features,
die wiederum dazu führen,
dass Forever Workstation nicht funktioniert.
Ein großes Problem bei Forever Workstation ist und
gibt es anscheinend jetzt auch ein Update, okay,
vielleicht ist es mit dem Update gefixt, aber ich glaube nicht,
ist, dass wenn ihr diesen Hyper-V Workload aktiviert habt
und Forever Workstation startet,
dann gibt es Probleme, dass
die Inputs, das Tastatur-Input und
Keyboard-Input laggy as fuck ist.
Ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, wie es ist. Ah ja, und es gibt
Probleme beim Scheduling von den Tasks.
Das heißt, Forever Workstation läuft nicht richtig, wenn
der Hyper-V Workload aktiviert ist, allerdings auch nur,
wenn ihr Windows 11 habt, wenn ihr Windows 10
habt, ist es wiederum kein Problem und dann funktioniert es.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir auch aufgefallen ist?
Da muss ich jetzt mal, Darkseid, du als krasser Windows-Hacker,
du weißt es doch bestimmt. Guck mal, Microsoft hat gesagt,
die Uhr in Windows 10, in Windows 11
darf keine Sekundenanzeigen mehr haben.
Wie bekomme ich wieder Sekunden? Windows 11 hatte das
by the way noch. Du konntest bei Windows 11 hier draufklicken
und da hattest du hier eine Anzeige in Sekunden.
Wie bekomme ich wieder Sekunden in meine Uhr?
Welcher Foldout bei Microsoft hat sich denn wieder gedacht?
Ah, Sekunden. Nee, das ist kein
agiles, bleeding edge,
nicest Windows-Features. Bloated.
Bloated Sekunden, Alter.
Selbstwitz mit Bordmittel nicht.
Überlegt euch mal, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Es hat allen Ernstes, wirklich, ohne Scheiß,
es hat allen Ernstes bei Microsoft irgendjemand gedacht,
Sekunden bei einer Uhr braucht man nicht.
Wie kommt man auf die Idee, dass eine Uhr
nicht mal optional...
Sekunden, Mann.
Wie dumm.
Wie dumm ist das eigentlich, Mann?
Keine Sekunden in der Uhr. Das ist so
hängen geblieben, was die da basteln, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht, was das soll.
Ich kann ja über die meisten Sachen immerhin wegsehen.
Solange sie eigentlich gängeln mit
irgendeinem Scheiß. Und das fuckt mich halt bei Windows 11
so richtig ab. Ja, es hat schon seine Vorteile,
aber es kann mir doch keiner erzählen so nach dem Motto
Max, du hast einfach nur noch nicht
die neue Designstrategie verstanden.
Das ist usability pur
ohne Sekunden. Nein, ich will Sekundenanzeigen haben.
Wisst ihr zum Beispiel, warum ich Sekundenanzeigen haben will?
Dass ich weiß, wann ich schon mal in ein Teams-Meeting
reinjoinen kann und wann nicht.
Ich will meistens nicht in das Teams-Meeting reinjoinen als
allererster, weil dann steht immer da,
Max erstartet die Besprechung und dann kommen die Leute rein und sagen,
ja, Max auch schon da. Musste immer
erst mal 5 Minuten auf Smalltalk halten, was nicht schlimm ist.
Die Leute bei mir sind wirklich alle super nett, kann ich nichts sagen.
Und das sage ich als jemand, der andere Menschen in der Regel nicht mag.
Aber trotzdem, ich gehe dann meistens immer pünktlich
kurz bevor die Uhr umspringt rein.
Aber was ist das für eine kacke, man? Warum ist da keine
Sekundenanzeige? Da kann ich mich so richtig reinsteigern
und mich den ganzen Tag darüber aufregen.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil die Tasklist ja
eine komische kastrierte
ME-Anwendung ist, kann man wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
irgendwelche gescheiten Änderungen da dran
vornehmen. Unter Windows 95,
98, ME, 2000,
XP
und wahrscheinlich auch noch Vista
und wahrscheinlich sogar bis Windows 7,
inklusive Windows 7,
konnte man ja nahezu alles mit der Taskliste
machen und moden. Also bis inklusive XP auf jeden Fall.
XP hat ja noch quasi die oldschool Windows 95-Leiste
unter der Haube. Und ab Vista wurde es dann
ein bisschen anders. Ab Vista gab es dann auch diese komische Suche hier und so was.
Allerdings trotzdem, ich meine,
Sekunden, guck mal, hier ist ja sogar noch
Platz. Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre hier kein Platz.
Guck mal, hier ist Platz. Man könnte fast
annehmen, hier würden genau die Sekunden reinpassen,
wenn man will.
Aber man will ja nicht, hat ja keinen Bock
bei Microsoft.
Es geht um die Performance, ja klar, natürlich.
Die Performance ist bestimmt voll im Arsch,
wenn die Uhr auf einmal Sekunden anzeigt.
Ich glaube, das bringt eindeutig
meinen
meinen, wo sehe ich denn jetzt, hat jetzt
Windows umgeschaltet, wo sieht man jetzt hier nochmal?
Alter, ich hasse Windows,
das geht mir auf den Sack. Wo sehe ich denn hier meine
meine, wo ist denn meine CPU-Anzahl auf einmal hin?
Wo ist da doppelt, achso, ich sollte vielleicht
ich sollte vielleicht CPU drücken anstatt Memory. Ja,
also Sekunden, Sekunden in der Uhr
wären garantiert performanstechnisch
mein
24 Kern, 64 GB Ram Rechner,
40, 90 RTX Rechner überfordern,
ich glaube, das schafft er nicht. Ich glaube, Sekunden in der Uhr
da wäre komplett vorbei.
Da kann jeder, Prime 95
alle Benchmarks können einpacken, Sekunden in der Uhr.
Jetzt vorbei.
Ausgelastet, 100%.
F.
Leute, soll ich dir was sagen? Guck mal da.
Ich habe da auch keine Sekunden eingeplendet.
Seht ihr das?
Und warum habe ich keine Sekunden eingeplendet? Weil mich die Sekundenanzeige
in der Uhr nervt. Aber ich will
die Sekundenanzeige im Overlay haben, so wie unter
Windows 10. Das ist okay. Hier habe ich auch nicht
eingeplendet. Aber hier kann man schnell aufs Terminal switchen
und gucken.
Ich aktualisiere tatsächlich anscheinend nicht Sekundenweise.
War mir auch neu, habe ich vergessen. Vielleicht sollten wir das
gerade mal schnell ändern.
Wo ist das?
Vielleicht sollten wir das einfach mal kurz ändern.
Intervall, wo ist hier?
Date-Time-Format, okay.
Prozents sind das Seconds?
Nein.
Doch.
Also richtig gemacht. Jetzt haben wir auch wieder Sekunden.
So muss das sein.
Es kann so einfach sein.
Man trägt dir das Format ein, was man haben will und schon
hat man Sekunden, aber nicht unter Windows.
Ist um 3% angestiegen auf einem Kern
von 24.
Selbst wenn es 3 Sekunden wären,
würde mich auch nicht jucken. Habt ihr übrigens gelesen,
es gibt jetzt eine 30 Gigabyte Festplatte
und die hat richtig geile Technik.
Die hat nämlich, wie heißt das?
Hammer hat das.
Hammer, das ist
pass mal auf, das ist
Heated
Heat Assisted
Magnetic Recording.
Die Festplatte wird irgendwie auf, also
ich habe es mir so ganz grob angeguckt.
Ich meine Terabyte,
nicht Gigabyte, Terabyte.
Die Festplatte wird erhitzt auf irgendwie 450 Grad.
Es kann auch mit Lasern sein.
Zumindest an den Stellen, wo geschrieben wird.
Die Festplatte wird erhitzt auf 450 Grad
und dadurch braucht man wohl
weniger Energie
für das Magnetfeld.
Und am Strich führt das dazu,
dass der Schreiblesekopf kleiner werden kann
und dementsprechend mehr Bits auf die Scheibe passen.
Aber das ist glaube ich noch ziemlich
ja so
experimentell kann man nicht sagen.
Fahrenheit oder Celsius macht bei 450 Grad
doch auch kaum einen Unterschied noch.
Das macht es auch noch mehr fett, ob es Fahrenheit oder Celsius
250.
Also das ist nicht wirklich experimentell.
Die
liefern das ja schon aus.
Aber das ist noch nicht unbedingt serienreif ready für
Konsumerprodukte.
Aber es ist coole Technik.
Lass uns doch mal angucken,
wie das funktioniert.
Haben wir jetzt nicht. Guck mal Wikipedia.
Gibt es das auch? Gibt es das auch auf Deutsch?
Die
zu Deutsch Wärme
unterstützte Magnetaufzeichnung.
Excellent.
Die Domäne.
Der Weißbezirk.
Was?
Klingt ja fast schon ein bisschen nach Racism.
Der Weißbezirk.
Ach so, das heißt so, weil der Typ das erfunden hat.
Ah, er war das. Okay.
Ach, das ist quasi die Einheiten auf dem Plan.
Doch, das könnte durchaus mit Laser funktionieren.
Könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen.
Also welche Daten geschrieben?
Das ist alles
klar, oder?
Zumindest passt mir auf die
Platte drauf unterm Strich.
Das ist das, worauf es aufkommt.
Worauf es aufkommt.
Und damit gibt es jetzt 30 Gigabyte Festplatten.
Was echt huge ist.
Und mal richtig großer Sprung.
Weil die letzten Jahre über hat sich zwar bei Platten
auch ein bisschen was getan,
aber es war lange Zeit so im Bereich, sagen wir mal,
14, 16, 18 Terabyte.
Und jetzt der Sprung auf 30 ist schon extrem.
Oh, gut.
Und da finde ich den nicht.
Allerdings sind die Dinger saumäßig teuer noch.
Gehe ich mal ganz stark von aus.
Die Performance sackt halt auch ein bisschen.
Steht hier glaube ich auch irgendwo drin.
Also was heißt die Performance sackt?
Das ist jetzt keine Platte, die
neue Geschwindigkeitsrekorde aufstellt.
Und
so.
ich glaube, es ist einfach auch noch ein bisschen
teuer für den normalen Anwender.
Auf der anderen Seite, Performance technisch ist
gar kein allzu großes Problem.
Warum habe ich denn immer mit Gigabyte?
Ich meine, Terabyte.
Also Performance technisch ist glaube ich gar nicht so schlimm,
weil im Ernst, wenn man das betreibt oder ein bisschen
ist aber ein bisschen höher preisige Storage.
Dann hast du da eh irgendwelche
SSDs drinne als Cache.
Und dann macht es
eigentlich das nicht großartig aus,
ob die Platte jetzt mit 80, 100,
150, 200 was auch immer
die Sekunde schreibt. Ich meine, schneller ist natürlich immer besser.
Genau, aber zwei Terabyte SSDs sind günstig. Also zumindest als Cache
sollte man sich einen reinhauen. Und insofern.
Naja, ich habe auch keine Festplatten mehr bei mir
eben, weil das stimmt glaube ich gar nicht. Lass mal kurz
gucken.
Doch, ich habe noch eine 13 oder eine 14 Terabyte.
Das glaube ich. 14 Terabyte Magnetfestplatte drinne.
Ansonsten habe ich eins,
zwei, drei,
vier SSDs drinne.
Richtig, mein Android Server hat auch noch
ein paar Magnetfestplatten drinne.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, für sowas ist das gar nicht schlecht.
30 Terabyte Platten, wenn die denn mal irgendwie
irgendwie erschwindig sind. Weil da ist die Performance ja nicht so wild.
Wenn man eine SSD oder vielleicht sogar
zwei SSDs hat,
die das
cacheen können alles, dann ist das nicht wild.
Eigentlich, also ich glaube, früher oder später
wäre das auch bei Home
Nassbetreibern oder
bei Reddit Data Horder ist das bestimmt so ein Einkommen.
Ja, die BX500 Sack, deswegen ist da auch nichts drauf.
Aber die hatte ich noch übrig. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, hey,
so eine SSD für Videoaufzeichnungen zum Beispiel,
weil die macht ja nicht viel, die macht 200 MB die Sekunde
oder so, für Videos reicht das, ist ganz praktisch, weil die
Nachzeiten sind ganz gut und mal gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da drauf mache.
Also aktuell habe ich es tatsächlich eher so,
dass ich hier ein bisschen Gaming Zeug drauf
habe.
Da fehlt noch eine, Leute, da fehlt noch eine.
Da fehlt noch eine.
Das sind
weird Flex, aber es sind eigentlich
5 SSDs, weil
das Laufwerk, wo ich mein Shadowplay Recording
drauf mache, ist nicht da.
Das mache ich nicht hier drauf.
Tja, gut.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Ja logisch, ich anmounte die, wenn ich mich abmelde
von meinem normalen Windows-Account.
Warum alles lokal und kein Nass dafür? Warum nicht lokal und
Nass? Naja, Games und solche Sachen und Videorecording
willst du schon auf irgendeine lokale SSD machen.
Also ja, du kannst theoretisch natürlich auch
das auf ein Nass machen, allerdings
da ist der 2 TB Cache jetzt auch nicht unbedingt das beste.
Mal angenommen, ich komme wieder auf die Idee und
warum habe ich ja nicht Linux Mint offen? Wollte ich das geil haben?
Ich komme wirklich auf die Idee und nehme mal einen armen Battlefield auf
oder ein paar Tage Battlefield auf. Also das kann
durchaus sein, dass das dann mit 2 TB irgendwie so an die Grenze
kommt relativ zackig nach einer Woche. Also
das ist nicht so gut. Am besten ist Videos lokal aufnehmen und
die Runden, die gut sind,
aufs Nass schieben. Funktioniert einfach besser.
Heute neue Distro probieren. Wir könnten uns,
wenn wir gerade dabei sind, was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn wir uns mal
Linux Mint angucken? Ich empfehle das immer.
Wir gucken mal ins Archive, weil wir das zuletzt gemacht haben.
Kann man das nach Datum? Oh, man kann das nach Datum sortieren.
Und man kann sogar
umstellen. Alter, man kann sogar mittlerweile
umstellen, dass man nur den Titel durchsucht. Hyper Feature
Implementation hier beim Archive.
Das ist ja extrem
ist das.
Jay, danke schön für den Sub und sorry, falls ich irgendjemand übersehen
habe vorhin. Wir können uns heute tatsächlich Linux
Mint, ich schreibe das mal in den Titel rein. Komm heute gucken wir uns
mal. Das kriege ich auch in eineinhalb Stunden hin. Soviel gibt's ja
da. Soviel gibt's ja da nicht nicht anzugucken,
weil ich empfehle das immer Linux Mint. Genau, Linux.
Kennt ihr das auch? Das ist ja der Bruder
von von Tempelo. Er ist Linux.
Wann kam das raus?
Release Date.
Linux Mint Release Date.
Victoria will arrive.
Können wir schon eine Beta ausprobieren,
wobei April, Mai,
Juni.
Okay, was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir uns das heute angucken
und im Juni wenn es rauskommt, dann nochmal, dass wir sehen, was sich
was sich getan hat.
Was sich getan hat.
Vera ist aktuell angesagt, kam raus.
Ach guck mal, kam doch erst, kam doch erst vor ein paar Monaten
Wir können uns tatsächlich angucken. Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, ich ändere mal den Titel.
Wo haben wir irgendeinen dummes, dummes
E-Mode dabei. Gibt es einen?
Gibt es einen?
Alter, ist das Pinguin E-Mode vielleicht hässlich von
Windows 11? Guckt euch das mal an.
Also das hier, das hier ist gut. Der Windows, der Windows
10er meine ich ist hässlich. Guckt euch mal
der Windows, guckt euch mal das Windows
10 Pinguin E-Mode an.
Ja, wenn, wenn, wie zeigt
haben die jetzt gar keine Windows, Windows 11 ist halt mega
hässlich einfach nur.
So, machen wir einfach mal hier so als Titel.
Ja, dann probieren wir das heute mal aus. Ich empfehle das
immer wieder Linux Mint, aber ich habe es erstaunlich
selten selbst benutzt. Schauen wir mal,
ob sich die Empfehlung lohnt.
Wie komme ich auf 10? Das ist doch uralt von 2010.
Ja, genau, das brauchen wir jetzt. Was ich bei
Linux Mint noch nicht checke ist, haben die nicht
vor einer Weile gesagt, sie wollen jetzt auf Debian
aufsetzen oder bringe ich das durcheinander
oder war das andere?
Ach so, hier unten
Debian Edition
Ja, gut macht eigentlich macht eigentlich nicht
wirklich wirklich Sinn, oder?
Wait, du siehst das 11 Emoji,
obwohl ich das 10er geschrieben habe.
Zum Beispiel für Apple.
Du könntest es auch von Android oder IOS
ausschreiben und die Dinger würden gleich aussehen bei mir.
Das ist doch Chebat, oder?
Ich hätte nicht von euch erwartet.
Doch ist es.
Das Emoji, wenn du das
wie nennt man das korrekt?
Ich glaube Codepoint nennt sich das.
Ich glaube Codepoint. Also wenn du wenn du das gleiche
Zeichen schickst, dann ist es
ist wichtig, was ich für ein System habe bzw.
eigentlich ist nicht mal mein System wichtig. Wichtig ist mein
Fond Renderer und den Emoji Fond, den ich benutze.
So, also laden wir das doch.
Gucken wir nochmal. Download Linux Mint
21.1
Die haben doch unterschiedliche ISOs. Ich dachte, das ist alles auf einer drauf.
Warum macht man mehrere?
Welche? Welche wollen wir denn?
Da war ich doch gerade. Ich würde sagen, wir machen Standard.
Wir machen wir machen Cinnamon und
Made. Ist das Wayland based? Ich hoffe nicht, dass
das Wayland based ist. Ist das Wayland based?
Dann bin ich, dann bin ich
mit meiner VM.
Wobei, wobei Wayland durchaus funktioniert richtig
konfiguriert, aber nicht gut in der VM.
Okay, download. Auf geht's. Let's go.
Downloads als 2,5G.
Ich will das nicht verifying. Ich will das einfach downloaden.
Ja, Germany.
Hochschule Essling. Ja, genau da.
Da wollte ich das schon immer, immer downloaden.
Warum Linux Mint?
Ehrlich gesagt, spontane Idee vom Chat.
Ich empfehle das immer, aber es ist schon glaube ich 2 oder 3 Jahre her,
wo ich das das letzte Mal ausprobiert habe.
Die Wayland Geschichte wird immer unsympathisch
und obstruse.
Ist halt wieder so ein typisches Linux Problem, dass die Leute sich da
so gegenseitig zeigen. VMWare sagt auch, da haben wir nichts mit zu tun.
Wayland sagt, da haben wir doch nichts mit zu tun.
Open VM Tools Leute sagt, da haben wir doch nichts mit zu tun.
Ist halt wieder richtig abfacke.
Das ist doch das typische Linux Problem, was ich auch schon
letztens im Streamer ausführlich angesprochen habe.
Distrowatch Mint. Ja, okay.
Okay, kein Wayland sehe ich das richtig?
Kein Wayland? Kein Wayland, oder?
Minus, Minus, Minus heißt kein Wayland.
Excellent. Sehr gute, sehr gute Sache.
Die Mainmaschine bleibt auf Arch, da garantiert bleibt die Mainmaschine
auf Arch. Ich bin bei mir auf der Arbeit sogar in einer...
Wie nennen sie das?
User Group oder sowas.
Im Prinzip ist es ein Teams Channel. Arch Linux User.
Gibt sogar einen eigenen Channel für bei uns in Teams.
Sind nicht viele Leute drin, aber...
Gibt, dass es einen gibt, ist ja das Entscheidende.
Du rewrites gerade das Archive-Backend.
Wie kannst du das Archive-Backend rewriten,
wenn du mit dem Archiv ansonsten nicht sonderlich viel zu tun hast?
Oder wie? Verstehe ich das jetzt nicht.
Oder einfach Just For Fun, du baust sowas nach.
Okay, legen wir mal kurz eine neue VM an.
Sowas wie Django plus für Rust.
Ich stelle es mir ehrlich gesagt eklig vor, damit zu arbeiten.
Weil Rust versteht mich nicht, weil ich sag's ja immer wieder.
Rust ist im Vergleich zu C++ tatsächlich eine ganz neisse Sprache.
Aber Rust ist nicht für C++,
Entwicklerproduktivität im eigentlichen Sinne ausgelegt.
Die Sprache ist auch sehr, sehr umfangreich und komplex.
Und hat ganz viele unterschiedliche Konstrukte.
Sondern Rust, finde ich, ist sinnvoll.
Allerdings nur in Bereichen, die...
Eigentlich in zwei Fällen.
In Bereichen, wo zusammenkommt, dass man Performance braucht.
Und es z.B. auch für C++.
Und es nach Möglichkeit Memory Safe haben muss.
Ohne in einer Managed Platform zu...
Oder auf einer Managed Runtime zu laufen.
Das ist der einzige Punkt, wo ich mir denke, dass Rust wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Zum Beispiel, ein Browser.
Ja.
Also zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal Firefox.
Firefox ist ein super Beispiel.
Für Rust.
Ich weiß, dass Firefox nicht auf Rust in dem Sinne basiert.
Aber Firefox, also ein Browser, ist ein gutes Beispiel
für eine Anwendung, wo sich Rust lohnt.
Das Ding braucht Performance und...
Es muss Memory Safe sein.
Also insofern ist das wunderbar.
Nicht umsonst hat Mozilla Rust erfunden.
Ich glaube ursprünglich für ihre CSS-Engine.
Bei Rusten bin ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher.
Welche Teile im Firefox mittlerweile in Rust sind und welche nicht.
Okay.
Ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Man will doch überall ordentlich Performance und wenn möglich
Memory Safety, oder nicht?
Die Frage ist, willst du sagen, nennen wir es mal so,
möglichst kompromisslose Performance
und nicht guter Memory Safety,
oder reicht dir auch gute Performance
und Memory Safety und
Entwicklerproduktivität?
Das ist bei den meisten Projekten würde ich sagen deutlich entscheidender.
Also kriegst du deine Anwendung in zwei Monaten fertig
oder brauchst du ein halbes Jahr für?
Ist die Performance jetzt nicht so wild,
ob das am Ende 100 Millisekunden oder 150 Millisekunden braucht?
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, Java ist ja
zum Beispiel, ich nehme jetzt mal Java als Beispiel
oder Go oder so, aber nehmen wir mal Java.
Weil Java ist im Büstersumfeld halt sehr beliebt.
Java ist ja nicht langsam oder so.
Java ist, wenn man sich mal so Benchmarks und Sachen anguckt,
ist Java wirklich ziemlich schnell.
Viele Anwendungen in Java sind scheiße, ja.
Aber Java selbst oder C Sharp auch.
Das ist alles ziemlich schnell.
Und selbst JavaScript, wo sich immer so drüber lustig kümmert,
selbst JavaScript ist verdammt schnell mittlerweile.
Wenn man nicht in irgendwelche doofen Optimierungs
so Edge Cases reinläuft.
Auch sogar blödes PHP ist nicht ganz so, aber auch relativ schnell.
Habe ich den Download nicht gestartet?
Ist doch schon fertig.
Ist doch nicht so was wie die Java VM.
Ja, genau.
.NET ist die Runtime,
ist das JVM Gegenstück von Microsoft.
Also die Dinger sind relativ schnell.
Was langsam as fuck ist, sind so Sachen,
also was wirklich langsam as fuck ist,
sind so Sachen wie Python und Ruby.
Allerdings, Python ist
von außen vor, weil viele Sachen,
die dort eben Performance Probleme machen würden,
sind gar nicht in Python selbst programmiert,
sondern in irgendwelchen C und C++ Modulen.
Deswegen kann ja auch dieses ganze Machine Learning
Zeug und AI Zeug
so gut in Python gemacht werden,
weil die den Kram eben in einer ordentlichen Programmierung
programmiert haben, wo Performance wichtig ist
und dann aus einer
Programmiersprache ansprechen, die sich gut programmieren lässt.
Ja, du, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Mach ruhig deine Sachen in Rust, ich will da gar nichts gegen sagen.
Aber Performance Memory Safety,
also kompromisslose Performance, das ist nicht immer das Einzige.
Managed Umgebung, sagen wir so was wie .NET und Java,
die sind von Haus aus Memory Safe,
wenn man nicht unsafe verwendet,
ist tatsächlich in dem Fall sogar ein bisschen wie in Rust,
wenn man nicht unsafe verwendet.
Und performanstechnisch reichen die für alles
normalerweise, was man so machen will, wenn es nicht gerade
Microcontroller sind oder irgendwelche Sachen, wo man halt weiß,
ok, da kommt es richtig krass auf Performance an,
wie zum Beispiel in einem Browser oder so was.
Ich kann mir nämlich zum Beispiel nicht vorstellen,
dass jemand auf die Idee kommt, eine JavaScript Engine
in, sagen wir mal,
PAP zu bauen, ok, das ergibt jetzt auch
Architektur technisch relativ wenig Sinn.
Ja, in Ruby.
Dafür wird es nicht passen.
Aber ansonsten ist das
meiste auch nicht
so viel langsam, aber halt in kritischen Anwendungsfällen
zu langsam.
Ja, genau das meine ich.
Genau das meine ich. C++ ist so ein typisches Ding.
Das Dumme, wisst ihr, was das richtig,
ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit C++-Rent anfangen.
Wisst ihr, was das richtig Dumme an C++ und Performance ist?
C++ dürfte glaube ich aktuell
mit die schnellste Programmiersprache sein, die es gibt.
Ja, ihr wisst, ich bin kein C++-Fan,
aber wenn es um Performance geht,
gibt es eigentlich nichts, was so richtig an C++ rankommt.
Ja gut, du kannst deine Sachen in C machen
und wenn du weißt, was du in Rust machst, ist das ähnlich.
Aber C++ ist eigentlich somit das Schnellste,
was du aktuell benutzen kannst.
Aber das Dumme an Performance in C++ ist,
dass alles so undurchsichtig ist.
Eine Sache,
die haben seit ein paar C++-Standards
ihre Move-Semantiks.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel, anstatt dass du
neuen Vektor initialisierst, kannst du quasi
den Inhalt von einer Liste
als Grundlage für den neuen Vektor nehmen, ohne dass du ihn quasi
die Werte deiner Daten da reinkopieren musst.
Da kannst du quasi deine Werte moveen
von dem einen in den Vektor. Wie auch immer.
Syntax absolut, pass mal auf,
Standard Move Vektor.
Ich meine, alleine schon,
alleine wenn ich, boah, Alter, mein Auge.
Ich meine,
alleine wenn ich schon diesen Mist hier lese, ja.
Ja, Qt ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Alleine schon, wenn ich sowas lese.
So, und...
Es geht schon gut los, man.
Es geht schon gut los, wenn ich sowas hier sehe.
Das ist so eine Schrott-Sprache, man.
Obviously.
Das geht ja noch, und das geht ja noch, Leute.
Das ist ja noch vollkommen in Ordnung, ja. Das kann man aber verstehen.
Okay, und...
Und da kommen immer so diese Dinger so mit.
Und die Find Behaviour und sonst was.
Aber...
Es ist dann teilweise...
Wie soll ich sagen? Der Typ muss es irgendwie unter...
Der Typ muss es dann irgendwie implizit unterstützen,
dass du Elemente da reinmoven kannst,
und man weiß nicht so richtig, wann das wie der Fall ist.
Und es ist so überhaupt nicht...
Überhaupt nicht richtig greifbar.
Das ist quasi Move Semantics von Rust.
Nur in schlecht.
In Rust ist das richtig gut gemacht.
Das ist, würde ich sagen, eines mit der besten Sachen in Rust.
Weil Rust das eben trackt, wo du wie was moves.
Und das lässt sich das einfach nicht compilen, ja.
Und nachdem es sich erst gar nicht compilen lässt,
kann sich Rust halt auch drauf verlassen,
dass es dann eben am Endeffekt auch halt nur so ausgeführt wird,
wie es ausgeführt werden soll.
Und braucht keinen kryptischen Shit.
Ja, es wird noch schlimmer.
Es...
Sie haben ganz, ganz merkwürdige Sachen.
Es ist, ja, das ist das Problem,
weil in C++ es so wahnsinnig undurchsichtig wieder gebaut ist.
Und manche Typen unterstützen es, manche Typen unterstützen es nicht.
Und dann guckst du auf Stack Overflow,
und da kommt dann irgendein C++ Typ und sagt dir,
Obviously, du benutzt ja auch einen Standort,
einen Standard, fragt mich nicht,
Hashmap, unsorted,
reverse map, tree, lookup,
Chrono, time, was auch immer.
So wie die Dinger da auch heißen.
Und dann sagen die, ja, obviously,
natürlich funktioniert das damit nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir aber, warum, warum funktioniert das mit dem Standard Vector,
und versucht es auch gar nicht zu verstehen.
Ja, ist so, ja, ist einfach so.
Ja, stimmt, ist eine gute Frage.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht angeguckt, was der neue C++ Standard hergibt in der Richtung.
Ich gehe aber ganz stark davon aus,
dass es wieder nicht einheitlich ist,
dass es wieder was weiteres Neues ist,
was nicht in allen Fällen gleich funktioniert,
beziehungsweise in manchen Fällen fehlschlägt
mit kryptischen Compiler-Meldungen, du weißt nicht warum.
Mein Lieblings, mein Lieblings C++...
Moment.
Natürlich ist es nicht einheitlich, was sonst.
Das war ja klar.
Leute,
ich hab, ich hab noch ein schönes...
Ich hab noch ein schönes Beispiel aus...
Das hab ich mir extra rausgeskopiert,
aus einem meiner Microcontroller-Projekte.
Ich bin mal...
Ich hab noch ein schönes Beispiel aus...
Das hab ich mir extra rausgeskopiert
aus einem meiner Microcontroller-Projekte.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wer mir von euch sagen kann.
Und dafür gibt es tatsächlich eine...
Der Erste, der mir erklären kann, was es macht,
weil ich hab's wieder vergessen, was es macht,
der Erste, der mir erklären kann, was es macht,
schlüssig, bekommt einen Prime-Sub.
Ihr Challenge, Leute.
Let's go.
Anyone?
Irgendjemand?
Möchte mir jemand erklären, was es macht?
Okay, wir fragen Chat-GPT.
Das ist eine super Idee.
Sekunde, ich muss mich kurz ausblenden.
Ich muss mich wieder einloggen.
Open AI...
Verify you are human.
Ja, bin ich, bin ich. Login.
Moment, Moment.
Open AI-Chat.
Sekunde, gleich haben wir es.
Login.
Auf Chat-GPT, mach hin.
So.
Next, next, next.
Okay.
Ich muss kurz heilen, meine letzten Suchern fragen.
Letzte Chance an euch, wer kann es erklären?
Bevor wir in Chat-GPT fragen.
Silver Cross, danke für den Sub.
Also, die Fall-Lokal...
Ja, das steht da.
Aber was es macht, was...
Gibt das aktuelle 1000er-Trend-Zeichen zurück?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ich frag euch ja.
Aber wenn ich es wüsste, will ich euch nicht fragen.
Okay.
Also, wir fragen mal Chat-GPT.
Was macht dieser C++-Code?
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Dieser C++-Code ruft die 1000er-Trend-Zeichen-Eigenschaft
aus der Standard-Lokalisierung C ab.
Das 1000er-Trend-Zeichen ist das Zeichen, das in einer nummerischen Darstellung...
Seriously, das 1000er-Trend-Zeichen
wird verwendet, um 1000er zu trennen.
Die Standard-Lokal erzeugt ein Lokal-Objekt,
das die Spracheinstellung enthält.
Der Parameter C gibt die Standard-Lokalisierung C-Lokalisierung.
Die Funktion Standard-Use-Faced
ruft danach dann das
Faced-Objekt Standard-Num...
Das bringt mir jetzt auch nichts.
Standard-Num-Punkt ab, das das 1000er-Trend-Zeichen enthält.
Das Template-Argument WeChat
gibt den Typ des Trend-Zeichens an,
welcher hier als white-Character-breites-Zeichen
verwendet wird.
Schließlich wird die Funktion 1000 selbst aufgenommen,
um das 1000er-Trend-Zeichen aus der Standard-Lokalisierung C zu halten.
Ja, alles klar, oder?
Also,
Leute, ich habe...
Ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr,
für was ich das benutzt habe.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es irgendwas war,
für Textformatierung
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das hast du auch irgendwie rauskopiert, oder?
Also, ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr,
wofür ich das verwende,
aber ich habe das aus einem realen Projekt...
Aber ich weiß meistens, weil das soll schon wieder
Use-Faced sein und so.
Also, ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr,
weil das soll schon wieder Use-Faced sein und so was.
Meine Güte, warum ist das so kompliziert?
Das war... Ich kriege es nicht mal zusammen, wofür das war.
Aber ich meine schon leider,
dass man 10 Minuten überlegen muss, was das macht,
ist doch schon wieder hängen geblieben.
Also, Standard-Lokal...
C ist ja Default-Lokal...
Okay.
Ich will rausfinden,
welches Zeichen...
Ich will rauskriegen, welches das
1000er Trend-Zeichen ist
für meine Standardsprache, nenne ich es mal, oder?
Das hier ist für meine Standardsprache
das 1000er Trend-Zeichen.
Also sowas wie ein Komma oder ein Punkt.
Und aus... Nee, hä?
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Bester Beispiel für Shit-C++-Kram, Mann.
Niemand versteht es.
Was Sie meinen?
Tatsächlich ein gekifte Tange.
Hat er es zuerst gewusst, ja?
Also, wie gesagt,
ich weiß nicht mehr, in welchem Kontext das war.
Ich vermute mal, bei irgendwelchem Texts...
Textlogging oder so.
Ich habe extra...
Also, wir lassen das jetzt...
Wir lassen es jetzt gut sein mit C++-Rent.
Aber nur für den Fall der Fälle,
dass ihr mal ab und zu was hören wollt, ja?
Ich habe eine Textdatei bei mir
im Notizprogramm.
Die nennt sich cpp-suck.
Das heißt,
die nennt sich cpp-sucked.
Und die hat mittlerweile
135 Zeilen mit Beispielen
so in dieser Richtung.
Also, ich habe da...
Ich habe da genug.
Danke schön für den Sub, Poggu.
Für den Fiatchen, der Quatsch, dafür habe ich nicht gebraucht.
Okay, don't save. Gibt es da eigentlich...
Gibt es da eigentlich Tickets oder sowas?
Oh, hier habe ich schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Was gibt es hier? Oh, hier gibt es neue Tickets.
Tickets. Post commands failing.
Oh, echt?
Ah. Ah, gut.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Und hier gibt es nichts Neues. Okay, gut.
Also, legen wir mal für Mint eine neue FM an.
Also, was haben wir denn hier? Custom.
Next.
Ja, next.
4 CPUs, cores, ne.
Ja, nicht 41, ich meine 1 und 4 Kerne, das muss reichen.
8G RAM sollte zum Testen auch reichen.
NUT ist auch gut. Jawoll, jawoll.
Single disk, 80G sollte zum Testen reichen.
Mint.
Hardware editieren, Printer weg.
Und...
USB weg und Soundkarte weg.
Okay, let's go. Auf geht's.
Ey, habe ich das nicht im Mint genannt?
Hallo? Please, ich möchte rename.
Renamen.
So, CD einlegen.
Downloads.
Mint Cinnamon.
Kein VM-Champ. Naja, für grafische Ausgaben ist der VM-Champ.
Ich habe Finished Installing.
Für grafische Sachen ist der VM-Champ ja nichts, dafür ist er nicht gedacht.
Interessant.
Interessant, guck dir mal.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass mittlerweile das Crap-Menü selbst in 16 zu 9 ist.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen FireMirror Workstation und FireMirror Player?
FireMirror Workstation hat ein paar mehr Features.
Ich glaube zum Beispiel Snapshots. Ich glaube Player hat keine Snapshots.
Und Snapshots sind eines der coolsten Sachen.
Ne.
Aber ich finde es ab und zu alle paar Streams mal ein bisschen draus herum.
Proxmox ist überhaupt keine Alternative dazu.
Proxmox ist eine Virtualisierungslösung in Richtung ESX.
Also auf einer eigenen, dedizierten Kiste.
Wenn du auf dem Desktop etwas virtualisieren willst, ist Proxmox nichts.
Und gerade für grafische Ausgaben ist Proxmox auch nichts.
Wenn du es hier auf dem Desktop virtualisieren willst.
Also insofern.
Das andere wirkt nicht großartig Konkurrenz.
So. Dann wollen wir doch mal.
Proxmox auf VM installieren.
Das haben wir tatsächlich sogar schon gemacht im Stream.
Das funktioniert auch zum ausprobieren, aber ja.
Also sinnig ist es natürlich nicht.
Kann es sein, dass es hängt?
Kann es sein, dass es gar nicht richtig startet?
Oh Leute, ich muss EFI um. Nee, es startet.
Ich muss das Ganze, wir können das Ganze schon mal ignorieren.
Ich muss das auf EFI Boot umstellen.
Weil wir wollen das Ganze ja schon unter halbwegs aktuellen Bedingungen testen.
So zack.
Ja.
Ich habe da gesehen, das bootet im EFI Mode auch gleich viel schneller.
Schöner Mauszeiger.
Der Mauszeiger gefällt mir.
Ich glaube.
Ohne Mist.
Ich glaube, den Mauszeiger hole ich mir für.
Für meinen.
Für meinen Arch auch.
Ich habe ich so einen.
Weil der ist jetzt nicht, der ist jetzt nicht irgendwie mega hässlich oder?
So einer Mauszeiger, aber.
Ja, also ein bisschen größer wäre schon ganz gut.
Gibt es das extra?
Nee.
Was habe ich denn aktuell für Cursor?
Ich habe aktuell Cursor.
Kapitane, ich habe Fake Mac Cursors.
Okay, ja, ich bin ich bin auch hier.
Auch einer von euch Leute.
Wir haben auch Fake.
Fake Apple Cursors.
Aber ich dachte mir, vielleicht gibt es.
Vielleicht gibt es den Mint Cursor hier auch.
Mint Maus Cursor.
Wobei wir installieren es einfach mal und gucken, wir können ja nachgucken, was es für einer ist.
Lass mal kurz schauen, wie guckt man denn hier nach?
Preferences wahrscheinlich.
Ach so, wir sind ja noch im Live System.
Nee, nee, ich ich installiere erst mal.
Ich ich installiere erst mal.
So install.
Ubuntu, das ist übrigens das einzig nennenswerte neue 33 04.
Es kam ja es kam ja quasi vorgestern das neue Ubuntu raus.
Ich glaube, dass das das einzig wirklich sinnvolle.
Ich mag den Minden Mauszeiger, der gefällt mir echt gut.
Ist der neue Installer.
Wie heißt der Bibata Modern?
Wie Bibata?
Material based.
Bibata Modern.
Modern Classic.
Schick.
Oh nee, ist das genau im Only? Nee, oder?
Der gefällt mir wirklich gut, der Cursor.
Welchen welchen braucht man jetzt davon?
2 2 0 3.
OK, Bibata Cursor Theme.
Bin Translucent Rainbow.
Ja, das untere ist es wahrscheinlich.
Sync Dependency.
Python Click Gen.
Das ist nur zum Bilden, oder?
Remove Make Dependency After Install.
Yes.
Probieren wir jetzt mal kurz aus.
So und jetzt und jetzt bliesst den ganzen Shit wieder deinstallieren,
den er als Abhängigkeit installiert hat.
Ja, aber Downloads, Leute, Downloads haben sie doch auch kein Problem.
Was?
Was ist er doing gerade?
Lass uns mal in den Chat schauen.
Hat hier heute noch jemand die Physi Abschluss Prüfung geschrieben?
Ja, Leute, erzählt, erzählt habt ihr Physi Abschluss Prüfung geschrieben heute?
Wer hat, wer hat heute? Schreibt mal in den Chat.
Wer hat heute Physi Abschluss Prüfung geschrieben?
Das interessiert mich.
Oder A.E. Abschluss, muss ich Physi sein A.E. Abschluss Prüfung?
Wer hat heute alles, alles Physi oder Fach Informatik Anwendungs an?
Oder Fie A.E.
Abschluss Prüfung geschrieben?
Leute, erzähl mal, was kam denn dran?
Was haben was wollen? Erzählt mal ein bisschen.
Das interessiert mich wirklich jetzt.
Physi 2023 News.
Abschluss Prüfung 2023.
War das heute?
26.04.
USV, ja Fragen zu USV kommen immer.
Erzähl mal, was war denn so?
Ja, bei mir ist es auch schon eine Weile her.
Das USV kam anscheinend dran.
ST wirklich?
Wirklich?
Ja, bei mir ist es auch schon eine Weile her.
Also USV kam anscheinend dran.
ST wirklich?
Die haben ernsthaft Spanning Tree Zeug abgefragt?
Ah nee, SFP versus SFP plus.
Oder STP, ja was denn jetzt?
Oder meinst du beides?
SFP versus SFP plus, RAID, DNS, IP, USV, IP.
Beides, Linker, Creation, STP.
Okay, da wollten sie es aber wirklich wissen.
Welchen Aufgaben-Teil habt ihr gestrichen?
Dann sage ich euch auch, was ich gestrichen habe.
Ich habe glaube ich den einfachsten Teil gestrichen.
Das gibt es nicht mehr?
Ach, das mit streichen gibt es nicht mehr.
Also ich kann euch aber sagen, was ich gestrichen habe.
Ich war einer der wenigen, der die Programmieraufgabe gemacht hat
in der Prüfung und strukturierte Verkabelung gestrichen hat.
Weil ich habe durchgeguckt, was machst du
und am Ende habe ich alles gemacht gehabt
bis auf strukturierte Verkabelung.
Das ist wirklich mit Abstand der einfachste Step habe ich gestrichen.
Und wahrscheinlich war ich einer der wenigen,
der freiwillig die Programmieraufgabe gemacht hat.
Haha.
Allgemeiner Teil, Klassiker mit Strukturkram und Pseudokund.
USV war aber scheiße, die haben nicht nach Berechnung gefragt,
sondern nach den Unterschieden zwischen...
Was?
USV? Was hat denn USV?
Zwischen V, F, I, V, I, V, F, D.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das sein soll.
Virtual, Virtual, irgendwas?
Das hat was mit USV.
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich hätte wirklich absolut keinen Plan gehabt.
Einfach Frequenzsachen oder so.
Also das hätte ich auch nicht gewusst.
SFP, SFP Plus hätte ich was zu sagen können, ja.
Im Netzwerkteil gab es keine einzige Aufgabe,
Subnetting oder Firewall, was soll das?
Ja gut, Subnetting ist E-overrated, outdated,
einfach IP-Calc verwenden und fertig.
Ich glaube, die meisten freuen sich sogar,
wenn dieser Mist nicht in der Prüfung drankommt.
Aber Firewall-Regeln sollten tatsächlich drin sein.
Ich finde, so ein bisschen, dass man verstanden hat,
so Firewall-Regeln, die machen dann nicht mal
große Tests, ob es stateful oder nicht stateful ist.
Das sollte da schon rein.
Ob da Subnetting drin ist oder nicht.
Also auf Subnetting könnte ich da verzichten,
Es gab auch eine Programmier-Aufgabe.
Kleines Programm erstellen, das sollte aus einem Array
mit Zahlen erkennen, ob mehr als 18 Einträge
über 80% liegen.
Äh, 80% von was?
80% von was?
Quatsch doch nicht, CPU-Last, oder?
Ach so, die Zahlen gingen von 0 bis 100,
oder was? Du sollst gucken, ob mehr als 18 Einträge
über 80% sind.
Ach so, ja, das ist easy.
Das hätte ich auch wieder gemacht und irgendwas
anderes gestrichen. Wobei, ja, wie gesagt, man darf ja nichts
mal streichen.
Also, ich weiß nicht, bis heute nicht,
was ich für eine Note,
also das hätte ich bestimmt irgendwo nachgucken können,
habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Hat der jetzt noch mehr Shit
hier installiert?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, ich weiß nicht, was ich in der Abschlussprüfung
für eine Note habe. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Also, vielleicht stand das irgendwo,
ich weiß es aber nicht. Ich glaube, es war keine,
also ich glaube, es war jetzt nicht super gut. Dafür habe ich
in der mündlichen Prüfung 95%, das weiß ich.
Insgesamtnote weiß ich auch nicht.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was ich hier ausstellen lassen,
den Zettel.
Okay, so, jetzt haben wir einen neuen Cursor.
Nicht, dass uns das jetzt, äh, wollte ich jetzt mal kurz
ausprobieren. So, Cursor, Cursor, hier.
Beaver Modern Classic. Alter, mir gefällt
das richtig gut.
Mir gefällt der Cursor richtig gut. Nehmen wir das in weiß
Bin das mal in weiß, dass man ein bisschen was erkennt.
Ja, mein Schwarz, okay.
Apply, so.
Und dann gehen wir in mein XInit rein.
Habe ich die Cursor-Größe hier irgendwo?
Ich habe keine Cursor-Größe, oder?
Ach doch. Cursor size 24.
Alles klar. Okay, starten wir mal kurz das Ding.
Und.
Das ist doch kein anderer Cursor jetzt, oder?
Hä?
Wait.
Habe ich nicht Applied?
Hä?
Häh?
Hö?
Hä?
Wohin Thumbnail?
Nee, Thumbnail fast.
Wo genau ist der Unterschied?
Der Unterschied ist, dass du solche Zeichen
machen kannst.
Dass du nicht doppelt drücken musst und solche Dinge.
So was hier zum Beispiel.
Also das Deadkeys sind komplett useless, shit.
Welche Distro ist das und welches Terminal?
Das ist,
by the way, muss man das natürlich erwähnen,
Archlinux.
Kombination
aus
Westerm als Terminal,
Archlinux als OS,
diese Icons und Themes,
i3 als Window Manager,
Auflösung, ZSH und
von der ZSH-Konfig sieht man nicht so viel.
Also wenn es dich genau interessiert,
gehst du einfach auf
GitHub,
Wobblers,
.files
und dann guckst du zum Beispiel hier
in die Konfig von meinem Prompt an.
So was zum Beispiel.
Kannst dir alles angucken.
Was ist das?
Ach, das ist nicht mein Projekt.
Das ist der Cursor.
TMUX oder Screen?
Weder noch,
ein ordentliches Terminal.
TMUX ist eine super Geschichte auf dem Server.
Auf dem Desktop will ich es mittlerweile nicht mehr haben.
Ich habe einen Terminal,
also in dem Fall ist es Westerm.
Ich habe einen Terminal, das kann splitten,
das kann,
das kann horizontal vertikal splitten,
das kann zoomen,
also Fullscreen machen,
das kann hier Panels switchen,
sogar übrigens mit Maus und Tastatur ordentlich.
Also mit Maus und
mit Tastatur ordentlich.
Man hat
diagonal splitten kann es nicht.
Du kannst mit der Maus auch die
Dinger verschieben, wenn du willst.
Ansonsten, was benutzt man in TMUX?
Normalerweise sonst noch häufiger.
Du kannst
neue Sessions starten.
Ansonsten,
das benutzt man in TMUX sonst noch häufiger.
Ich glaube das sind so die Standardsachen.
Serious Max, ja das geht nicht,
wobei ich glaube gelesen zu haben,
dass es mittlerweile auch irgendeinen
Demon Mode oder sowas gibt.
Und das hat den Vorteil,
wenn man das hier im Terminal hat,
man kann TMUX auf dem Server starten
und muss dann nicht doppelt
escapen.
Install Multimedia Codex,
ja mach mal.
Jetzt habe ich Back gedrückt, ich wollte
eigentlich auf Continue drücken.
Leute, ich habe den Installer geprickt
durch einen einfachen Klick auf Back,
so wie es ausschaut.
Nee, doch nicht.
Okay, braucht bloß ewig.
TMUX ist sehr nice, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, du kannst alles,
was du normalerweise in TMUX
alltäglich benutzt,
auch mit einem Terminal machen,
wenn das eben
die passenden Funktionen
im Terminal haben.
Du kannst es auch mit einem Terminal machen,
wenn das eben
die passenden Funktionen
im Terminal haben,
wenn das eben
die passenden Funktionen
unterstützt. Und dann hast du nicht das Problem,
wenn du auf dem Server bist, dass du
TMUX in TMUX laufen darfst, mit SSH
dazwischen, teilweise die
Farben rumbacken, deine Escape-Sequenzen
rumbacken und du doppelt escapen musst,
wenn du im Server was machen willst.
Also ich finde es viel viel angenehmer,
lokalen Terminal zu haben, was die
Sachen wie Splits und sowas machen kann
und dann TMUX auf dem Server starten. Das ist
die beste Kombination, die ich mir vorstellen kann.
Okay, excellent.
Preparing Ubuntu...
Ubuntu Drivers Erase.
Jawoll, alles erasen.
Continue.
So, wir sind in Berlin.
Max...
Max Virtual Machine,
besser Name überhaupt. Passwort, Leute.
Best Practice Passwort.
So...
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das
fair ist.
Ich habe eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs genommen.
Also mein...
Zumindest in meinen Anzeigen, Achtung dein Passwort ist
mega abgrundtief schlecht.
Könnte, könnte, könnte das...
Könnte das schon, ja?
Fair ist eine...
Fair heißt ja eigentlich sowas wie
okay, ja?
What the fuck,
Alter?
Was...
What the...
Alter!
Was ist denn jetzt
los?
Okay, ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich,
was will er? Was hat er
für Schmerzen?
What the...
Was ist... Hä?
Ich zeige euch mal was,
Leute. Sekunde.
Vorhin, als ich auf
YouTube in die Analytics
geguckt habe von meinem aktuellen Video,
sah das noch ganz normal
aus.
Und, und seit
keine Ahnung, zwei Stunden
oder so,
ist das, macht das Video mega
stonks.
Guck mal, hier habe
ich geguckt vorhin.
Hier irgendwo habe ich geguckt und jetzt auf einmal
zu...
richtig big stonks.
Das Video habe ich in 30 Minuten
aufgenommen, zusammengeschnippelt und hochgeladen.
Das ist so ein richtiges, so ein richtiges
Low Effort Video gewesen.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich fand das Thema
wirklich spannend, aber ich bin auch total,
total spät dran.
Das Gameplay haben doch, ich dachte,
das haben alle schon gesehen. Ich sage
einfach mal was zu, so mein Senf,
weil ich habe das selber heute Morgen
zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Aber anscheinend kommt das,
kommt das gut an?
Hyper stonks, ja.
Ich habe es heute Morgen zufällig das erste Mal gesehen.
Leute, man merkt, wenn man spät dran
ist, wenn sogar die ARD da drüber
schon berichtet hat. Die ARD
hat da heute Morgen was zugesagt, man.
Hat mir mein, mein,
mein Social Media
Experte,
Manager,
erzählt,
dass ich
dass sogar die ARD das heute Morgen erzählt hat
in irgendwie
auf irgendeiner Seite von ihnen, keine Ahnung.
Also dann weißt du, du bist spät dran.
Schau mal, woher die Views kommen.
Das sieht man noch gar nicht so richtig
im Detail. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann nur nachgucken.
Die Views kommen von
YouTube Recommendations.
Auf YouTube.
Auf der Startseite.
Und.
Im Subscription Feed.
Logischerweise.
Ja. Und
external, external gibt
es auch relativ viele Aufrufe.
Also die Verteilung ist wie folgt.
13.000 Views
kommen von der Startseite.
4.000 Views kommen
von, vom Subscription Feed
jetzt. Und
externe, von extern kommen
2,5K.
Aber da sind auch viele von
von Twitter und
rübergekommen und sowas.
Ich muss das mal kurz vergleichen, wie das zum
Beispiel aussieht. Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Kurz gucken, mit meinem letzten Video.
Äh.
Da ist external
so gut wie gar nichts.
Hat mich irgendeine
Newsseite
oder so verlinkt.
Kann das sein?
Hat
irgendeine Newsseite mein Video
verlinkt oder sowas?
Weil es sind erstaunlich
viele aus external jetzt.
Man sind immerhin, immerhin
an die 10% oder so
der Viewer von external.
Okay, Moment.
Das muss, das muss ich jetzt
mal kurz äh.
Ein Twitter.
Twitter kommt normalerweise immer ein bisschen
was rein, aber nicht 10% der
Viewer.
Sekunde, wir checken das jetzt
einfach mal kurz. Man sieht
leider external nicht von wo.
Suchen wir
mal danach an meinen Video-Titel.
Hm.
Um ein Video, warum ein Video so abgeht
ging es gerade drum. Und ansonsten
haben wir gerade äh, Mint, LuxMint
installiert.
Ich will mich mal nicht
beschweren.
Ist schon okay, darf ruhig Views
geben, ja.
Früher hat man gesehen woher die
external Zuschauer kommen, aber ich glaube
das, das sieht man mittlerweile nicht
mehr. Man, man sieht wirklich
nur external, man sieht
nicht.
Man sieht nicht wo von
external.
Ich glaube, das gibt
es nicht mehr.
Okay.
Das passt.
Jaja, irgendjemand hat mich
verlinkt. Ich weiß nicht wo, keine
Ahnung.
Ich sehe das, ich sehe das, also
das Video
das, das ging
steil.
Aber, aber
mit einer Stunde später kamen dann auch die ersten
external Aufrufe rein, also
hm.
Leute, versteht mal irgendjemand was auf
YouTube abgeht. Das checkt, checkt
eh niemand.
Egal.
Nee,
external ist ja alles möglich, also wenn
mich irgendeine Newsseite verlinkt hat, dann
man sieht
es halt nicht mehr.
Warte mal.
Wir fragen
mal, das interessiert mich jetzt echt.
YouTube Analytics
See which
external source.
How do I find
external traffic source?
Moment.
Aha.
Sitze mal.
Leute, ich mache seit
seit 13 Jahren YouTube, ich habe
keine Ahnung von YouTube, wo wir wieder beim Thema
sind. Dass ich wahrscheinlich
der planlose YouTuber auf der Welt bin,
was das angeht.
Analytics.
Okay.
Reach
external
traffic sources.
Google Search
über die Google Suche.
Die Leute suchen schlicht und
ergreifen danach und finden mein Video
über die fucking, das hatte ich ja
auch noch nie, dass 10%
der Viewer einfach random über die
Google Suche kommen, Alter.
Über die
Google Suche.
Ja, nice. Okay.
Soll mir recht sein.
Kein Ding, kein Ding.
Passt.
Next.
Google Suche darf mich ruhig weiter promoten.
Der Videotitel ist aber ganz catchy.
Leute, falls ihr irgendwelche Fragen und Sachen
von euch übersehen habt, schreibt es ruhig nochmal
in den Chat. Ich habe gerade die letzte Zeit
nicht reingeguckt.
Oh, es werden Leute gebannt. Hier geht es wieder zur Sache.
Hat Mint
mittlerweile Vollwert Tools installiert?
Ja, anscheinend nicht.
Das finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Seriously, ich könnte
mir vorstellen, es ist doch kein
großer Akt oder
vor allem
Tools standardmäßig zu installieren.
Das könnten sie doch machen.
Abinstall
Open
VM
Tools.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Desktop
und
nur Tools?
Was?
Was macht es?
Ich weiß nicht, wir installieren
es einfach mal.
Oh, zack, Fullscreen. Nice.
Da haben wir Linux Mint am
Start. Was haben wir denn hier? Ein Linux Mint
Cinnamon Edition.
Du benutzt Mint seit einem Jahr und bist
sehr zufrieden? Ja, ich empfehle
Mint auch immer hier im Stream für Einsteiger.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es
bei mir glaube ich selbst schon zwei oder drei Jahre
her ist, wo ich mir das das letzte Mal angeguckt habe.
Also das Wichtigste ist erstmal, dass ihr alles
ein bisschen größer stellt. Ich meine
Boomer Augen, das geht doch nicht so.
An A-A. Es ist
ein 515er Kern.
Ah ja, geht doch. Geht doch in Ordnung.
So, also
ist jetzt nicht Steinzeit.
Ich weiß nicht,
wann vor 515 rausgekommen ist.
Wahrscheinlich vor
drei, vier Monaten oder so.
Nee, wann kam das raus? Steht das auch
irgendwo dabei?
Ja, 22
Jahre. Ja, okay, vor einem
halben Jahr. Also ist nicht mehr taufrisch.
Wobei, das
erscheint mir ein bisschen sehr alt, ehrlich
gesagt.
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen sehr alt.
515 Linux.
Das müsste, der muss neuer sein, eigentlich.
Weißt du, wie blöd
Blogposts sind?
Nee, das ist tatsächlich fast schon
ein halbes Jahr alter Kernel.
Da ist bestimmt neuer Kernel dabei.
Ja, aber
kein Major Versionsupgrade.
Das passiert ja in der gleichen
Release nicht.
Sogar noch älter als ein halbes Jahr.
Upgrade mal.
Es gibt keinen neuen Kernel
dafür.
Das ist der neueste.
Steam soll ich, warum soll ich Steam installieren?
Willst du einfach nur wissen, ob es
Steam ist oder nicht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob es Steam ist oder nicht.
Willst du einfach nur wissen,
ob es funktioniert?
Können wir machen. Ich werde mich hier nicht einloggen
und spielen können wir in der VME nichts.
Also wir können gucken, ob
Steam dabei ist und starten.
Macht Mint eigentlich
auch diesen Müll von Snaps
wie Ubuntu? Das muss ich jetzt gleich mal
überprüfen. Lass mal kurz in Chrome
starten. Ist das Firefox?
Ist das ein Snap?
Nein, es ist kein Snap.
Es ist ein echter
Firefox.
Nicht dieser
Müll, wie es Ubuntu macht.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Abbrechen. Next.
Es ist schon gleich viel schneller. Easy.
Mint entfernt Snap und
baut Firefox und Chrome selbst.
Sehr gute Entscheidung.
Die Leute
bei Canonical, die sind mehr damit
beschäftigt, sich zu überlegen,
wie sie das System mit weiteren Snap-Müll
voll klatschen können,
anstatt mal irgendwie zu überlegen,
was man mal wieder Innovatives machen
könnte.
Mint Key Selling Point
ist ja, dass es kein Snap ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der Key Selling
Point ist, was übrigens richtig
krass business stonksmäßig klingt,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall
für mich ein großer Pluspunkt,
dass es keinen Snap hat.
Restore Session hier, aber wir haben keine
recent history.
Ach, Snap
sagt,
oder?
Benutzt, benutzen die
wirklich, wirklich, benutzt er wirklich
Mint? Ja, gut, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber
Snap, das Schlimme
ist, dass sogar Snap mittlerweile sagt,
bitte starten Sie jetzt mal ihren Firefox neu
und wenn du es nicht neu gestartet hast,
wir werden ihn dir unterm Arsch wegziehen
innerhalb der nächsten 10 Tage, wenn du nicht rechtzeitig
neu startest und sowas.
Also, das ist eher was, was man von Windows kennt
und nicht von irgendeinem ordentlichen Linux.
Ich meine, ich starte den Kram meistens eh
nach Updates öfters mal neu
und lasse es keine 10 Tage laufen, aber
trotzdem, muss ja nicht sein.
So, auf jetzt, mach mal hin, Updater.
Updater,
Updater mal.
Bisschen, bisschen zackiger.
So, das mit Steam kann ich tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Was, was ist das hier?
Oh, ich hätte nicht über
CLI upgraden müssen, ich hätte auch einfach
hier upgraden können.
Na, gut.
So, was systems,
man kann Systems
aufbauen,
man kann Systems Snapshots damit machen.
Do you want to switch to a
local mirror?
Ja, okay.
Ja, wir hätten das gleich mal testen sollen
über das UI,
was ja viele Leute machen.
Packages, hier.
Dogadu GmbH.
Okay,
und Base, Base
Images kommt hier von
von denen.
Ja, ganz toll. Okay.
Ja, ist schon mal ganz gut,
dass das alles geupdatet wird.
Über das UI.
Und wie gesagt, ihr kennt mich,
ich bin kein großer Fan von irgendwelchen
UI Updatern und Sachen.
Aber ich glaube, für den
normalen User ist das halt
Was ist denn jetzt los hier?
Die FHR
Islam, oder?
Meine Internet Connection ist in Ordnung,
so viel kann ich euch sagen.
HostingEurope.de, okay.
Und das hier gibt
Dogadu,
was ist das?
Ronix, die Friedrich Alexander
University of Erlang.
Ja, auch gut.
Let's go.
Jetzt, easy, hat funktioniert.
Ja, hab ich schon gemacht. Sorry.
Was? Hab ich? Nein, das war alles
gut.
Okay.
Gut, wir können ja über das UI nichts updaten,
weil ich hab ja gerade übers... Ich mag
das Cursor-Theme.
Das gefällt mir wirklich gut. Ich muss mal gucken,
wie ich das auch unter meinem Manjaro,
äh, nicht Manjaro, unter meinem Art-Stilungs-Zool
aufgehe. Das Cursor-Theme, das gefällt mir.
Das hat echt was.
Close.
So, wir haben den
Clipboard, ne.
Oh, ich hätte gedacht, das wäre ein Clipboard-Manager
da unten.
Ne, jetzt ist er wieder weg. Gibt es
kein Clipboard-Manager?
Das System ist... Und wie
macht man hier Snapshots?
Angeblich kann es Snapshots machen.
Ah, hier, es ist zum Snapshots.
Aha, aha.
R-Sync, ja gut, wir haben nicht auf
BTRFS installiert.
Okay, dann ist es
quasi
ein R-Sync-Frontend.
Aber nicht schlecht, dass so was direkt
dabei ist. Ich mein, warum nicht? Ist doch
eine coole Sache.
Ja gut, das testen wir jetzt nicht. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich mein, ich hab eine VM, da kann ich auch so
Snapshots machen. Okay, wir starten
mal neu.
Wenigstens mal ein Menü, wo man was drin findet.
Wir starten mal neu, dass er auch die neuesten
Kernel und die ganzen Updates lädt. Und dann
gucken wir mal wirklich, ob man Steam über den
Package-Manager installieren kann, ob das auch
startet.
Wie gesagt, ich kann mich jetzt nicht einloggen, weil ich
meine Daten nicht da hab und was spielen in der
VM geht eh nicht.
View Kernels soll man machen.
Okay, hier gibt es
irgendein
First Step Documentation.
Ach ja!
Ja, das ist ja schick. Das gefällt mir.
Ja, das gefällt mir gut.
Guck mal, das hier. Das gefällt mir tatsächlich
gut, dass du direkt gleich im
Was haben wir denn? Modern?
Traditional?
Modern.
Ja, kann man schon ein bisschen
größer machen. Mit Boomer-Augen ist kein Ding.
System-Snapshots hatten wir schon. Driver-Manager
Gut. Hä, ja.
Da gibt's für vor allem. Das ist
gut gemacht.
Ihr wisst, ich bin da immer sehr pingelig, aber das
sieht wirklich sehr
so aus einem Guss aus. Ist ganz gut, dass
ich Mint empfehle wahrscheinlich.
Update Manager System Settings
Launch
Das ist easy. Das könnte meine Mutter auch benutzen.
Sogar mein Vater würde das hinkriegen.
Dann würde er sich wenigstens
sein Rechner nicht so voller Viren hauen.
Er hat wahrscheinlich keine Viren, aber
dann ist die Gefahr nicht so groß.
Leute, ich war letztens mal meine Vater.
Weil sein Rechner nicht ging.
Ich hab mich breit schlagen lassen und
der Typ hat ernsthaft. Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Also ich hatte eben
da mal Windows 11 drauf
installiert. Da ist ja Windows Defender dabei.
Der Typ hatte drei zusätzliche
Virenscanner installiert.
Überlegt euch das mal.
Drei zusätzliche und Windows 11.
Der hatte installiert
Avira.
Oh fuck.
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zu. Das waren drei Stück.
Das erste hat sich gar nicht.
Malware Bites?
Avira, Malware Bites?
Was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Bekanntes.
Bitdefender oder sowas, glaube ich.
Ich glaub Bitdefender.
Avira, Bitdefender und
Malware Bites.
Alter, was hast du
auf deinem Rechner gemacht?
Ja und Windows Defender.
Software Manager?
Können wir starten? Okay.
Und die Firewall können wir starten.
Nicht, dass man das jetzt wirklich brauchen würde.
Normalerweise.
Dann die Luxkiste.
Ah, das ist UFW.
Das ist so ziemlich das hässlichste
und useless Firewall UI.
Was mir so einfällt.
Aber ich find das sehr schick gemacht.
Hier, da findet sich auch jemand.
Also wirklich jeder damit zurecht. Gar kein Ding.
Gut, das ist das Standard Software Center.
Das kannst du eh. Brauch ich nicht, ja.
Hotco... Moment.
Gibt es Wobbly Windows?
Gibt es die Möglichkeit
Wobbly Windows zu machen?
Das brauch ich Leute. Sekunde, Sekunde.
Das muss ich checken.
Mint.
Wobbly Windows.
Extension.
Jawoll.
Cinnamon Spices.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Irgendein...
Ist das irgendein Plugin Manager?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Copy the files?
Oh nee, das ist ja abartig.
Das ist ja eklig gemacht.
Quatsch, kein Anti-Virus installieren, ja.
Welche Files denn überhaupt?
Download.
Ok, Download.
Komm mal gleich mal gucken, ob ich Zips extra hin lasse.
Wir machen das jetzt mal wie der letzte Kacknoob hier
übers UI.
Ich muss jetzt nach Punkt Local.
Da fängt es schon an.
Wie lässt man sich hier was... Schau hin, Files.
Ok, das Local.
Nee, wohin muss es hin?
Local Share Cinnamon Extensions.
Und das muss da rein. Einfach so?
Ja, anscheinend.
Und jetzt?
Enable Extensions Cinnamon Settings plus Button.
In den Settings, hier bin ich.
Cinnamon Settings soll ich.
Extensions.
Da ist es.
Jetzt.
Wichtig.
Wie aktiviert man das jetzt? Enable.
Jawoll.
Hast du Kack Javascript?
Du meinst, das ist Javascript?
Pot?
Aber endlich.
Ja, so mag ich das.
Das gefällt.
Das ist kein Pepega Plugin.
Das ist so ziemlich das geilste, was es eigentlich früher
gab unter Linux, unter normalen
Window-Managern.
Leider, leider gibt es
Compets in der Form
und Weise irgendwie nicht mehr.
Das ist das Einzige,
was ich an E3 vermisse.
Weil E3 hat keine Fenster in dem
Sinn. Na doch, E3 hat Fenster.
Aber, aber E3
und Compets
gehen halt nicht zusammen.
Das gefällt mir.
Das muss ich behalten.
Cool wäre jetzt, wenn...
Moment, man...
Warte mal.
Man kann das direkt hier runter, drunter...
Moment.
Man hätte es direkt hier von runterladen können,
Leute.
Ich hätte überhaupt...
Ich hätte das überhaupt nicht kopieren müssen.
Das ist ja sogar noch besser, als ich gedacht habe.
Okay, lass das mal.
Sekunde, Sekunde, wir
disablen das mal wieder.
Die sammeln bei mir wirklich Pluspunkte
gerade, finde ich, finde ich sehr,
sehr nice.
Wir löschen, wir löschen das mal wieder.
Mal gucken, ob das on the fly...
Okay, da geht's los. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Hier wahrscheinlich.
Okay, Extensions, Extensions.
Wir löschen das mal wieder.
Also, mal gucken.
Jetzt sind die Extensions weg.
Was?
No.
Okay, yes.
Download.
Compets.
Compets, ja.
Guck mal, man kann es direkt hier runter...
Ja, das ist ja nice. Das ist viel besser,
als irgendwie so einen Shit,
den man sich aus dem Hintert runterladen muss.
Und jetzt?
Können wir einfach sagen Enable?
Ja.
Ne.
Something
went wrong. Ich vermute mal,
weil ich es einmal runtergeladen habe
und einmal so...
Ich glaube, damit kommt da nicht klar,
wenn es schon mal geladen war, runter war.
Das ist das Falsche, wirklich?
Ne, das ist
das Richtige.
Hermos 83.
Das ist das, was ich eben runtergeladen habe.
Compets Window Effect.
Hermos 83. Das ist das Richtige.
Das ist...
Das ist das Richtige.
Find ich gut gemacht.
Hier kann man Settings von einstellen.
Was ist mit dem da drüber?
Keine Ahnung, aber wir müssen jetzt
erst mal rebooten,
weil das allerwichtigste ist, dass
Wobbly Windows funktioniert.
Ohne Wobbly Windows ist ja useless.
Da ist Twiess. Danke für den Sub.
Useless.
Pass auf, jetzt geht's.
Wobbly Windows.
Wey, jawoll.
Endlich, endlich Wobbly Windows.
Okay, ich sehe mich da tatsächlich,
das ab und zu mal zu verwenden, das System.
Allein schon, weil es Wobbly Windows hat.
Das ist das beste Feature ever.
Ich verstehe ja immer noch nicht, warum
sie Compets in die Tonne gekloppt haben
und nicht einfach weiter
Compets
weiterentwickelt haben und
Mainstream-mäßig verwenden unter Linux.
Aber das ist einfach das Beste hier.
Was haben die denn sonst noch für
Wobbly Windows?
Extensions? Ich weiß, das ist ja so wirklich
Distro, nicht wirklich Distro testen,
aber
viele Sachen sind es ja nicht.
Desktop Cube?
Das ist auch für den Oldschool
Compets Effekt natürlich sehr nice.
Compets Cube.
Enable Hotkey?
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Ja, stimmt. Wie switche ich eigentlich
Desktops hier?
Ah, haben wir das nächste. Wie switche ich
zwischen mehreren Desktops?
Workspace Manager.
Enable Workspace.
Allow Cycling through Workspaces.
Yes.
Ja, okay, wunderbar, aber
was hier vorne ist Workspace?
Ist gar nichts, oder?
Ja, ne.
Unten rechts, ne, das ist eigentlich
Desktop-Anzeigen.
Vielleicht muss man das
auch explizit hier wieder rein
machen, das kann ja schon sein.
Äh, Applets?
Hier muss man das bestimmt irgendwo...
Ne, Applets sind die Dinger hier rechts,
oder nicht?
Workspace-Switcher, da ist es doch.
Okay, jetzt haben wir
den Workspace-Switcher, aber wie man den
Würfel...
Wie man den Würfel aufmacht,
weiß ich nicht, aber das ist tatsächlich
echt nicht schlecht, gefällt mir.
Gefällt mir wirklich ganz gut bis jetzt.
Hotkey, tja, ich würde
den Hotkey suchen, wenn man den...
Also wenn der Hotkey da stehen würde,
steht er ja nicht, man kann ihn in
Settings, aber, ja.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach
mal hier auf die Hilfe-Seite
gucken, Desktop-Cube, wir haben doch
den ganzen Krampel doch offen gehabt.
Extension, was sind denn Desklits?
Ah, so Widget-Geschichten.
Okay, da bin ich, da bin ich
ja eh kein großartiger Fan von.
Was, Control-Alt-Up?
Äh, das ist hier...
Desktop-Cube.
Das wollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Nice, super.
Does not work, oh.
Control-Alt-Left-Right.
Ja, da switch ich VMs mit,
das ist natürlich blöd, das ist...
schon...
Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Also das ist dann wirklich
nicht der deix.
Nur deretic, ich workshop
immer house.
und das wiegt Fairy,
dass kann der einfach
Hau und Breaking News dahin dienen.
Die finde ich links,
nämlich die Services recreation.
Das dann Raptor hier,
Partikel burning.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Also da wird dieses Extension Zeug
wohl auch sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt,
weil es macht jetzt auf mich
nicht den Eindruck, als gibt es da
viel.
Wisst ihr, eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich
benutzen würde, wenn irgendeine
gute Distribution
auf Compets wieder mal aufbaut.
Oder Compets weiterentwickelt
und das verwendet. Compets war einfach das
geilste überhaupt.
Aber irgendwie gibt es da nicht mal richtig.
Compets war einfach das beste.
Da kannst du die geilsten Sachen machen
auf dem Desktop.
Unter anderem Wobbly Windows.
Also da gucken wir mal, ob wir Steam finden
über diesen...
Wie ist das Ding? Packages oder sowas?
War das das?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das noch gibt.
Software hieß das glaube ich einfach.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir da drüber Steam finden.
30.000 mal Steam.
Steam, FlatHub,
IGIT, Package.
Install.
Intel driver, ja unbedingt.
Die brauche ich, ganz klar.
Intel driver.
Aber gut, ey, ist doch nice, dass
es das im Package Manager gibt.
Schon mal deutlich angenehmer,
als unter Windows
den Crempel zu installieren.
Über KDE, nee, über Compets.
Weil du konntest Compets auch mit
KDE benutzen. Aber
ich verstehe nicht...
Ich verstehe nicht,
wie sie sowas geil...
Die hatten sowas geiles
Going quasi.
So 2008,
9, 10,
11 vielleicht
noch rum.
Was Linux desktops anging
mit Compets.
Und das haben die einfach, die haben
sich da komplett zerfahren wieder.
So richtig Linux typisch,
einfach die Sache wieder in Sand gesetzt.
50.000 Objekte,
Projekte gefolgt,
50.000 verschiedene Window Manager
Standards, Composite Manager
Standards, und im Endeffekt ist Compets dann mit
untergegangen. Und das wäre eigentlich
das Ding gewesen, das hätte auch die Leute überzeugt.
Alter, boah!
Also Steam und Wobbly Windows hast du seine
Probleme.
Wie
beendet man Steam jetzt
eigentlich, wenn man hier unten keine
Icons hat?
Oder ist wenn ich zu klicke Steam
automatisch wieder?
Ja, okay, Steam.
Vielleicht läuft das auch gar nicht im Hintergrund
gerade.
Ne, anscheinend, anscheinend gar nicht, ja.
Wobbly Windows nervt dich, nein.
Scheiß Leute, Wobbly Windows
ist das einzig wahre.
Allerbeste, Wobbly Windows.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Leute, ich muss jetzt
gleich pennen, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns das wirklich
ausführlich morgen oder so nochmal fertig an.
Natürlich, allerwichtigste
Test, was haben wir für Default Backgrounds?
Und was, was war das?
Ach so, das waren diese komischen
Widgets.
Fast, das ist ja fast
ein bisschen.
Das ist ja fast ein bisschen wie Windows
Vista war das doch mit dieser
komischen Uhr, oder?
Kann das Sekunden?
Hallo,
bei PS4.
Hallo?
PM?
Und jetzt?
Ja!
Das funktioniert, nur, dass wir nicht
sondern, dass wir
Stunde haben wollen.
Nee, PM war nicht so.
Nicht mal so schlecht.
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal
rot im Hintergrund?
Irgendjemanden planen?
Haben wir
was kaputt gemacht?
Ach nee, das ist, weil ich
in den Settings
drin bin.
Ja.
Gar nicht mal so übel, finde ich, finde ich
tatsächlich ganz, ganz okay. So die
Hintergründe sind jetzt eher nicht so geil.
Haben wir da?
Weihnachtliche, weihnachtliche Stimmung.
Norwegen.
Ach guck mal, die Schweiz.
Ah, gibt's, gibt's ein paar.
Ist mir alles, ist mir alles zu hell.
Ah, Grass.
Grass ist gut, das kann man lassen.
Retro.
Ja.
Grass.
Also
an sich macht es auf,
ich glaube, wir sollten uns das wirklich mal in Ruhe fertig
angucken.
Es macht es auf den ersten Blick wirklich
einen ganz niceen Eindruck, muss ich sagen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht, das zu empfehlen.
Ich, ich, ich
verstehe immer noch nicht genau, warum
man nicht damals mit Compets weitergemacht
hat. Da war wirklich Desktop Linux
so 2007,
2008 rum, war
Desktop Linux wirklich auf dem
guten Weg mit Compets, weil es hatte
halt was, wo so, es war so ein richtiger,
richtiger Hingucker, wo dann auch
Leute gesagt haben, oh geil, Alter, das will
ich auch und sind damit in Kontakt gekommen.
Aber das ist halt
diese typische Linux-Geschichte wieder.
50 Projekte
und irgendwie ist dann irgendwann ist
Compets halt untergegangen. Klar, man hat
so einige der sinnvollen Funktionen ja jetzt
auch in die Standard-Window-Manager übernommen.
Aber was mit Compets
möglich war, war einfach geil.
Von Wobbly-Windows, von diesem komischen
Würfel, da konnte man ja eine Fenster
abfackeln lassen.
War nice und ich will nicht wissen, wo das heute
wäre, wäre das weiter
entwickelt.
Die wollen die Gimmicks nicht jeden
Tag. Ja, und musst ja nicht benutzen.
Du kannst ja Compets auch so konfigurieren,
dass es einfach nur
grafisch beschleunigte Oberfläche war
und sowas. Aber du konntest halt so cool
es Zeug machen.
Ja, Wayland und Compets kannst
du eh vergessen.
Kannst du in Wayland Wobbly-Windows machen?
Mit irgendwas?
Bestimmt,
oder?
Ja, Compets,
es wird nicht mehr wirklich viel gemacht.
Das sieht man auch an den Comets leider nicht.
Es gab ja noch mal Compets
Reloaded oder wie das hieß.
Also ohne Mist, so blöd es klingt.
Ich glaube Ubuntu von 2011
oder so, mit
Compets noch integriert, dürfte
auch heute noch optisch,
also gemodded, dass man es ein bisschen
optisch cool macht, eines
der größten Hingucker-Distributionen
schlecht überhaupt sein.
Also es macht einen ganz guten
Eindruck. Max FPS
LOL. Warum?
Warum ist das LOL?
Du meinst, weil du den Stream gefunden hast wahrscheinlich, ja.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast, aber ich bin
gar nicht Max FPS, ich bin ja Wobblos.
Wobbly-Windows-Effekt in Hyperland, siehste?
Siehste? Siehste, Leute?
Ich sag's euch.
Das war einfach superior
damals.
Kein Wobbly-Windows-Effekt hier
selbst für neue hippe
Window-Manager.
Äh,
überhaupt wobbelt nichts.
Aber hier wobbelt was.
Esse.
Wobbly-Windows, einfach...
Wir gucken uns das, Leute,
wir gucken uns das morgen in Ruhe mal fertig an.
Ich glaube, da gibt's echt noch einiges zu entdecken
und ich muss ja wenigstens wissen,
was ich den Leuten als Einsteiger-Distribution
empfehle. Bei der Gelegenheit können wir uns
dann auch mal Mate angucken, vielleicht geht ja
Mate plus Compets.
Alter, das, das wäre extrem
Poggo.
Ja, Compets Reloaded.
Ja, da gibt's kaum noch Compets beim
ordentlichen Compets und beim
Reloaded.
Da sind wir ja gerade, ja.
Da gibt es kaum noch, kaum noch Compets drinnen.
Da tut sich nichts mehr.
Seriously, das ist dead.
Das ist dead, das Projekt.
Was halt echt
bitter ist. Compets war das
beste, was es je gegeben
hat auf dem Linux Desktop.
Und das wäre meiner
Meinung nach echt so ein Ding gewesen,
was, was der ganzen
Sache zumindest auf dem Desktop mit zum Durchbruch
hätte helfen
können.
Aber, tja.
Da starten sie sich halt selbst den Weg.
Mein, für mich heutzutage ist es egal.
Ich benutze E3, da ist eh nichts mit
Composition großartig und Wobbly
Windows.
Aber das wäre schon cool gewesen.
Der Ubuntu Installer
ist neu, ja nur der grafische Installer.
Habe ich gelesen.
Also der grafische Installer
scheint, scheint mir neu zu sein.
Leute, wir gucken uns morgen den Rest an.
Es war auf jeden Fall, ich weiß nicht, was es
vorgeschlagen hat, aber ich muss sagen, es war eine sehr
gute Idee, das vorzuschlagen.
Und
ich bin jetzt
und ich muss
bis jetzt sagen, mir gefällt das von
den Sachen, die wir uns angeguckt haben.
So Top 3 mäßig
bis jetzt. Also das macht
einen durchdachten Eindruck und es ist auch
nicht so wie bei vielen Projekten, wo man dann
in drei Optionen
klickt und denkt, ah okay, sieht auf den ersten
Blick gut aus, aber ist auch nicht durchdacht oder
ist auch nur ein Standardzeug, macht wirklich
einen guten Eindruck, ja.
Ich muss
ins Bett, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis morgen, CU.